es el momento más esperado por miles y
miles de personas que a lo largo de
estos cuatro días han querido ver a la
monarca recordemos que haya estado
ausente de la mayoría de estos eventos
oficiales del jubileo de platino un
momento histórico para este país porque
ha tenido problemas de movilidad bueno
la monarca ya tiene 96 años y
naturalmente está teniendo problemas
para caminar para moverse por ello no
asistió a gran parte de esos eventos
programados pero sí hubo euforia por la
aparición de la reina isabel segunda
unos minutos desde el balcón del palacio
de buckingham completamente vestida de
verde con sombrero y lo hizo con la
línea de sucesión al trono británico con
tres futuros reyes con su hijo carlos
con su nieto william y con el príncipe
george esta es la manera muy sutil de la
reina isabel segunda muy a su manera de
decir miren este es el futuro de la
monarquía este es el futuro de la
monarquía
así que la gente está feliz porque la
reina apareció nuevamente por unos
segundos como puedes ver a mis espaldas
después de la fiesta ha iniciado el
proceso de limpieza de las calles de
londres y es que la capital británica
como el resto del país estuvo de fiesta
durante cuatro días pero hoy se vivió un
carnaval lleno de música de festividad
de arte de artistas que hicieron un
recorrido por la historia de este país
en los últimos 70 años en los que isabel
ha sido la protagonista la monarca desde
su ascensión al trono de
1953 hasta nuestros días pudimos ver
como les digo un recorrido por la
historia por la moda pero además fue un
momento bien emotivo porque circuló el
carruaje de la reina isabel segundo en
el que se llevó a la abadía de
westminster cuando fue coronada hace
casi 69 años un carruaje de oro que
tiene 260 años de historia pero también
pudimos ver
de los objetos de los
pasiones de la reina isabel como muchos
caballos muchos perritos corghi y por
favor el after
y es que además hoy fue el día de los
almuerzos masivos los rings en
diferentes zonas del país porque fue una
celebración no solamente aquí en londres
y la familia real sino lo que se
esperaba es que el público en general
pudiera compartir este tiempo récord los
70 años de isabel segunda en el trono